- Yeah.
- Cool.
- [Speaker 1] Break a leg.
- (sighs deeply) Hey, everybody.
Thank you for coming this afternoon.
My name is Jason Levin.
I am the director of
partnerships for Luma AI.
And today, we are here to talk about
the path to multimodal
artificial intelligence.
If that is not what
you're here to talk about,
then you are in the wrong room.
So,
language models like
Gemini, ChatGPT, Claude,
they are incredibly capable.
Most of us probably use
them every single day.
But they don't understand
the physical world.
They don't know how people move,
how objects interact, how light behaves.
And so if AGI is gonna
interact with the real world,
the place where we all live and breathe,
it needs to understand visual
and spatial intelligence,
not just linguistic intelligence.
So humans, we think visually,
and AGI has to as well.
So at Luma,
our mission is to build multimodal AGI.
And we build video models because video
is the closest representation
of the real world
that we can teach to an AI model.
When we say "multimodal AGI,"
what we mean is models that
can generate, understand,
and ultimately operate
within the physical world,
from a product sitting on a shelf
to a character walking through a scene,
or even a robot navigating a home.
But building these models
requires enormous amounts of compute.
Thanks, that's where
AWS comes and helps out.
And it also requires
world-scale training data.
So that's why we are proud to announce
that we recently raised our
$900 million Series C round,
and this funding allows us
to train the next generation
of multimodal models,
models that truly
understand motion, physics,
spatial reasoning, and continuity,
because AGI is multimodal
and the training data, the
dataset, it's reality itself.
When a model can keep
a character consistent,
understand spatial depth,
simulate particle physics,
follow instructions, and
maintain continuity over time,
that's a form of world understanding.
This is the foundation of multimodal AGI.
That's why we created Ray3.
That's our state-of-the-art
video generation model.
Video isn't just images in motion.
Video encodes physics, cause and effect,
timing, behavior, camera
movement, and context.
And a system that can generate
and reason about video
is building an internal model
of how the real world works.
Ray3 is our most advanced
step towards that goal.
To walk you through the
model's capabilities,
text-to-video, image-to-video,
dynamic motion,
HDR and EXR output, keyframes,
reasoning, there's a ton,
I'm gonna hand things over
to our resident expert.
So please welcome Davicho Barona,
who will take you through Ray3 in-depth.
- Thank you, Jason, I appreciate that.
Thank you guys for being here.
Before I go too much further,
I really want to touch on
just a couple of the things
that make Ray3 really special
and that make it stand out
from all the other rest of
the video models out there.
Number one is the Ray3
reasoning model, and this is,
I'll touch on this a little
bit deeper in a minute,
but this is a model
that judges and refines its
own output in real time,
trying to match your instructions
without you even necessarily
looking after it.
And then the ability of Ray3
to export HDR and EXR files
directly out of Dream Machine
is also super special.
A lot of VFX teams out there
and compositing artists
and post-production teams rely
on this kind of file format,
and it's something that
stands out and stands apart
from all the other models out there.
And I want to touch on some
of the model's strengths.
These are sort of the bright spots,
some of the places where
we see Ray3 really shining
and really standing out here,
starting with physics simulations,
particles, fluids, explosions,
the way that Ray3 is able to deliver
really high motion fidelity
and really stable simulations,
natural flow of particles,
coherent fluids,
and really consistent and
punchy explosions on-screen.
Then moving to world motion,
understanding, exploration.
This is the way that Ray3 kind
of travels through the world,
and just showing really
strong spatial reasoning,
maintaining true depth,
perspective, seamless motion,
really stable sense of
scale, and just coherent
across all kinds of
different environments.
Then character anatomy, action, animation,
different art styles,
just the way that Ray3
is able to preserve anatomical accuracy,
expressive movement,
fluid action sequences,
keeping characters really
consistent, believable,
and just the really punchy
and exceptional performances on-screen.
To close-up details, lighting effects.
The way that Ray3 is able
to preserve those really fine details,
clear textures, surfaces,
all kinds of lighting,
handling reflections, glows, shadows,
all while staying really consistent
and true-to-life in that sense.
Here's a quick reel that
I want to show you guys.
This encompasses a lot of those points
that I just mentioned here.
Let's just watch this together.
(dramatic music)
(piano dings softly)
(air whooshes)
(dramatic music crescendos)
(rhythmic drumbeats)
(piano dings softly)
(thunder crashes)
(dramatic music accelerates)
(piano dings softly)
(dramatic music continues)
(pulsating music)
And you actually just watched
a bunch of the different functions
of Dream Machine here in one.
You saw some image-to-video,
text-to-video,
some keyframe animations,
and even some of the sound
effects that you heard there,
I created directly in
Dream Machine as well.
Now I want to touch on
some of the new features
that Ray3 brings into play,
starting with the HDR and EXR outputs.
This is a huge step forward
and no other model does this natively.
And again, the way that it
exports HDR and EXR files
allows a lot of different
pipelines out there
to have a lot more
control over the output,
exporting anywhere from
10- to 16-bit EXR files
and allowing those compositing artists,
post-production folks, VFX artists,
to control those layers of color
unlike any standard video
generations out there.
Here, just a quick example here,
the raw flat HDR output
here on the bottom left,
and then just push
into a couple different
color space examples here,
in this case, like, the
day mood, night mood.
And this is by being able
to edit those different color layers,
which is not a standard feature
of any other video generator out there.
And then moving on to that reasoning model
that I alluded to before,
the way that it's able to reason its way
through your generation,
judging its own output,
refining its own output,
all by understanding your instructions
and try to accomplish
the best result possible
without you necessarily even being there.
It annotates on its own and
finally comes up with a result
that it feels fits your
instructions the best,
and then will upscale that,
allowing you to sort of be hands-off
and saving some credits
in your experimentation,
if you will.
From there, touching on the
visual annotation mode here,
something that's really, really
cool for creators to use,
supporting the ability for anybody
to just sketch or scribble
directly on-screen,
telling the model what elements
to move where, when, how.
And for example, onscreen as you can see,
directing that fish, "Go this
way," or as you saw before,
bringing in that UFO element from the top,
moving the cow up in a
certain direction, et cetera,
and that cat jumping from stone to stone,
all while you're literally
just onscreen annotating
with your mouse or your
Wacom pad, for example.
From there, another really
awesome feature of Ray3
is this draft mode.
And draft mode allows you
to create these low-res 360p previews
before actually committing
to a high-res upscale,
allowing you to kind of
stay in that creative mode
a lot more seamlessly and
conserving your credits
and being able to experiment
a whole lot faster
than with your standard 720 or 1080.
And then you can upscale into
those other resolution modes
within Dream Machine as well.
From here, touching quickly
on the compatible features of Ray3,
starting with image-to-video,
of course, turning static
visuals into cinematic motion.
Text-to-video, we all are
very familiar with this,
bringing your ideas to life
through your written instructions.
Modify Video, the ability
to transform videos
by either editing a start frame
or just with a simple prompt as well.
Extend, keyframes, and loop,
extend being the ability to
extend the length of your videos
by five seconds at a time,
either at the beginning or
at the end of the video;
keyframes, transitioning
from one frame to the other;
and then loop, being able
to seamlessly create,
or to create videos
that are seamless and
endless loops as well.
Just touching on that
image-to-video aspect here,
as you can see,
this was my original keyframe
image down here, left.
And then just looking
at some of the motion
that that keyframe is hinting at.
And the model is picking up on this.
I'm not using any prompt
when I'm creating this,
just feeding it the image
and letting the model do its thing.
And as you can see,
there's kind of this motion
that is inherently built into this image
that you can tell the
video is picking up on
where even those like,
particles on the sides
that are moving fast
and the beard and the hair
kind of moving really
gently in that breeze,
those lightning bolts showing
that delicate kind of
endings to them as well,
even down to those reflections
on that like, wet skin surface there.
Doing a great job here
with that image-to-video instruction only.
Then touching on the
text-to-video aspect of things,
here I'm using a really short prompt.
I'm just controlling the details
that are really important to me,
like the shot type, macro close-up,
the subject, a rattlesnake,
in that moment where it's about to strike.
And I'm, all the other details
that are missing from my prompt,
I have more trust that an
advanced model like Ray3
is gonna come up with
those details on its own
in a way that's really pleasing to me.
And so in this case,
it's doing really well
with kind of super-short, direct prompt.
And then touching a little bit further
on that prompt adherence piece,
Ray3 is really improving those
instruction understanding,
and adapting to all kinds
of different prompt style,
different prompt lengths as well,
and just showing really accurate
results and being reliable
with all kinds of
different style of prompts,
whether it's that super-long,
story-style prompt
that maybe you get out of an LLM,
where it has all kinds of
color, very, very detailed,
it's doing great at those long prompts,
down to kind of a concise version of that
on the right top side over there,
where it's like the one
to three sentence prompt,
doing great there.
Over to the bottom left here,
that kind of laundry
list style of a prompt,
where you're just kind of
rattling off those keywords,
doing great with those
kinds of prompts as well.
And then over to that really short prompt
that you saw in action before.
I kind of tend to live
over on the right side,
between the one and three
sentence style prompt.
That's just kind of my preference.
But Ray3 doing great at understanding
all kinds of different
prompt styles as well.
Then touching on modified
video, a really cool feature.
Here, I'm just showing a side-by-side
of this basic Newton's cradle video here,
where, by just editing the start frame
or by giving it a basic prompt,
I'm able to edit that video
and isolate certain objects,
for example, those metal spheres,
changing them into something
completely different
very quickly and very efficiently here.
From here, I want to touch on
that keyframe interpolation,
that start and end frame animation,
where it's just doing great
at transforming these stills
into truly dynamic sequences
and generating these really
smooth, natural transitions.
And it just feels super
seamless and cinematic,
and it feels really natural.
And as you can see down
here on the bottom left,
my start frame and my end frame,
and then these interpolation markers
that I'm kind of testing against,
starting with that seamless scale shift.
As you can see, that start
frame is a medium shot
and the end frame is a closeup shot,
and it's going from one to
the other really seamlessly
making it seem
like it's truly a single
shot from the beginning.
Then that material fidelity,
going from these sort of
hard edges in his armor,
to this like translucent,
very like ethereal look
in that closeup and doing
it really naturally,
really feels like it was
like this in a single shot.
The lighting continuity,
again, not over-brightening,
not darkening,
just keeping it really true to
my original instruction here
in these keyframes.
The cinematic flow, again, it
feels like it's a single shot.
And even with that camera movement
as it zooms in to that closeup shot,
it kind of even jolts back a little bit,
making it seem like it's
truly part of a single shot.
The structural coherent,
nothing is really falling apart here.
All the lines, all the
different elements here
are staying together really well.
And then the color harmony,
I did pick two frames that
are sort of similar in color.
But I just want to showcase
how it doesn't deviate from that.
It truly holds true to the color
that came with those keyframes.
Then touching on advanced style adherence
and the way that Ray3 is able to excel
at this image-to-video feature,
preserving that original
keyframe look and feel,
the vibe that comes built
within that keyframe,
and just doing it really well
across all kinds of different motion,
across all kinds of
different styles as well.
And then putting it up against
these aesthetic markers here,
just to point some of these out,
the lighting, again, not
brightening it, not darkening it,
just staying really true
to that original keyframe.
The camera effects, that
shallow depth of field.
Even as the camera slightly
zooms in on his face,
you can still see that that
focal plane is staying true
according to that original keyframe,
and the bouquet lighting in the background
looks really exactly the same
as what the instruction told it to.
The film grain and that texture
looks really, really
accurate to that keyframe.
It's not over-sharpening it,
it's not making it look very AI-ish,
it's not making it look
too kind of Photoshoppy.
It's really keeping true
to that original keyframe.
The moody atmosphere, really
reading this keyframe.
And I'm not using a prompt here either.
This is just image-to-video
without any reinforcing prompt.
And it's picking up on
that kind of like intensity
that's built into that keyframe
and doing a great job translating that,
not changing that too much at all.
The color palette,
also something really
important in this case,
where you can see those
blacks are very muted,
the highlights are also muted,
and here it's staying true to that.
It's not darkening those,
it's not making it look like something
other than what that
keyframe is telling it to.
The surface details,
those droplets of sweat maybe on his face,
the raindrops in the background,
even down to those
individual hairs as well,
everything is staying really intact.
The retro aesthetic, I'm a huge fan
of like old-school kung fu movies,
and so I generated this keyframe
to sort of test against that.
Holding up really well.
It truly looks like this
was still shot on film.
It's got that true 1970s kind of look here
and I absolutely love the way
that it holds true to that input.
And here, talking about
the video extend feature.
Before I play this video,
I just want to point out
that this original keyframe that I used,
you can see that that warrior is standing,
already standing at the top of that cliff.
But as you look at this
starting frame here,
he's actually climbing up.
And I'm just trying to point out
that you can extend before or after,
at the tail or at the head of the video.
And as I play this, just take a look
at how smoothly and how fun
this sequence can really be
as he sort of flips off that
cliff, turns into this eagle,
and then goes across that valley
back over to this mountain.
He continues to climb up this hill
and then gets picked
up by the snow leopard,
apexes this hill, and then
it completely switches over
to a whole new scene,
seamlessly going down
and kind of immersing you
into a whole other scene here.
And for this video, I made this in a day.
Mind you, I'm not a VFX artist.
And it took me about 90 different videos
to kind of put it together in
a way that I really liked it.
And that translated to about 90 bucks.
There is no way that I
could do this in a day
with any traditional tools,
and certainly not with
a $90 budget either.
And then finally, touching
on that video loop aspect,
starting with this keyframe
down on the left here,
I'm creating a seamless looping animation
that really, you cannot tell
where it starts or where it begins.
It's just taking you through this journey
without even knowing that
this is actually looping.
I was a GIF animator, like
close to 10 years ago now,
and I would've absolutely killed
to have this kind of control
and these kind of tools back then.
So all of that, I will
switch it back to Jason.
But just to give you kind of an insight
into all the different features
and all the different
capabilities of Ray3.
- Thank you very much, David.
- You bet.
- So,
now that you've seen
what happens behind the scenes with Ray3,
let's take a look at what it's capable of
in the hands of professional
technical artists.
We have a a short sizzle video here
so that you can kind of see
what the range looks like on Ray3.
- [Film Narrator] When
you close your eyes,
what do you see?
When we talk about reality,
how do you know what is real?
Or what is simply
your imagination?
Imagination? Imagination? Imagination?
(intense music crescendos)
Now, open your eyes.
(soaring adventure music)
(soaring adventure music intensifies)
(climactic musical beat)
- So for enterprises, this
isn't theoretical anymore.
This is real and in-market,
and video generation
is the first real step
towards multimodal AGI.
It's already transforming
how companies create product
videos, campaign assets,
cinematic scenes, and
world-scale environments.
So let me show you what this looks like
across the industries that we serve.
We're gonna go through
some cool use cases.
Across every brand that we work with,
we hear the same thing:
It's that content demand has
outpaced human production.
Video production still costs
thousands of dollars per finished minute,
social platforms keep
increasing the pressure,
and two-thirds of major brands
have already rebuilt
their production pipelines
in just the last four years.
Models that understand the
world visually and physically
unlock a path to producing content
at the speed that modern
media requires of us.
People now expect content
that speaks directly to them,
their tastes, their culture, their region,
but brands need 10 times more
video assets per campaign
to deliver that level of personalization.
They simply can't keep up.
You can't build teams
fast enough for this.
So this is where generative
video goes from nice to have
to existential advantage.
And one of the first questions
that we get from enterprises
is ownership, copyright, and data safety.
So we built Luma Enterprise
around these three guarantees:
Protected inputs and outputs,
your data sits in a walled garden;
full commercial ownership
of everything you produce;
and indemnification on what you produce.
Luma has your back legally.
And Enterprise is produced
with Luma in two key ways.
As we've already touched
on, there's Dream Machine,
which is our web and iOS SaaS platform.
And you can access all of our AI models
through that platform.
And then you can also access
each of our models such as Ray3
through direct integration by
API for high-volume pipelines.
So let's start
with one of the most
immediate areas of impact,
consumer packaged goods and e-commerce,
near and dear to my heart personally.
So creative teams tell us
that the hardest part isn't the finals,
it's exploring enough ideas quickly.
And Ray3 lets you generate
dozens of directions,
refine, remix, and then produce
fully realized video assets
from those explorations.
As you can see here,
you know, we've got this same hoodie
across a bunch of different models,
in different scenes, different
backgrounds, different poses,
all generated with AI in
a fraction of the time.
This would typically require
multiple photo shoots.
It would be a very expensive process.
With one product photo,
brands can instantly generate
product lifestyle photos.
So something that used to require a shoot,
location, lighting, and a full crew
can now be done sitting at your laptop,
any time of day, anyplace.
We're also able to reframe videos.
So every platform requires
different aspect ratios:
TikTok, Instagram, LinkedIn,
YouTube, YouTube Shorts.
For content teams,
this is a big burden and a big bottleneck.
So Ray3 lets you reframe a video
to any aspect ratio you want.
It will maintain composition,
lighting, shot intent,
while adapting to 9:16, 16:9,
4 by 3, and plenty of others.
And some of the cool things about it are
it will dynamically
outpaint the missing content
based off of the context of the video,
or you can give it a text prompt
and tell it what you would
like in the missing space.
Something else that's cool that you can do
is you can drag the subject of the shot
into different parts of the frame
so that you can change what the subject is
or change how it's positioned.
So if you want to go
from a center frame shot
and then turn it into a
Quentin Tarantino-style,
you know, one-third video shot
where you've got three people in frame,
or for marketing teams,
if you want to free up
some space in that shot
to put marketing language superimposed,
it allows you to do that as
well, which is really powerful.
From a single product shot,
we can produce multiple
hero angles, macro shots,
motion passes, and product
demos, as you can see here.
This compresses days of studio workflow
into literally minutes.
We can also reuse old
product shots as new assets.
This is huge for brands
with large archives.
Old photography becomes new campaign video
without any reshoots required.
Now let's talk about PDP.
For those that aren't
in the e-commerce space,
this is product display pages.
So PDP video lifts conversion rates.
Any brand in the room that
handles e-commerce volume knows
that product videos see a
click-through and conversion boost
over still images.
Ray3 creates seamless motion loops
from keyframe images of your products
so brands can enhance every SKU page
without needing new footage.
That's an immediate and easy
revenue bump for brands.
Large brands spend millions of dollars
on product video shoots,
and SMBs can't afford
to turn their entire product
catalog into videos, until now.
So here's a cool example
where, rather than
animating the whole video,
we've just told the model
we want to animate the
ocean in the background,
keep everything in the foreground static.
No problem, it can keep
the foreground static.
We've just added a little
bit of life to this image
for a product page to
increase our conversion rate.
That translates immediately
to increased bottom line revenue.
These apparel examples were created
from a single still frame each.
And these examples are one-shot examples.
These are not cherry-picked.
This is the very first
generation out of the model.
It adds natural body
mechanics, fabric motion,
camera drift and depth cues,
all while maintaining
brand-consistent lighting and color.
When people shop for clothing,
they want to see how the fabric moves,
how it drapes on a human body,
how it's going to look on a real person.
And this allows us to
simulate that really easily.
We can also do fast ad variants.
Performance marketing teams love this.
One product, many environments,
many styles, many moods,
each generating new creative
for A/B testing at a massive scale.
We can do demographic-specific
assets as well.
Localization is no longer a bottleneck.
Ray3 generates culturally-specific scenes
for different regions, different holidays,
different seasons,
without any new reshoots.
This is crucial for global brands
who need to distribute assets
across global market
segments very quickly.
We can also produce new complex scale.
And this is where world
modeling becomes really obvious.
Crowds, dynamic camera moves,
underwater worlds, complex environments.
These used to require huge
teams and huge budgets.
Now a single creator can
explore these concepts
at full scale.
It's incredibly empowering.
I love this ant example. This is great.
And we can replace the flags
in this with any team we want,
any corporate logo, even a made-up team.
So sometimes brands want precise control,
where an object should
appear, how it should move,
how the scene should flow.
We can interpret annotations,
just like a creative collaborator.
You can just speak to
it like another human.
- [Speaker 2] You should be able to do it.
(engine revs)
(bouncy tropical music)
(water whooshes)
(bouncy tropical music continues)
(birds cawing)
- So all of this functionality
allows brands to create targeted ads
in a fraction of the time
and a fraction of the cost.
Here's an example for Adidas Floral.
(singing in foreign language)
(water trickling)
(singing in foreign language continues)
- [Speaker 2] I'm gonna
switch you back after this.
- So in film and episodic production,
we're seeing some of the
most exciting adoption.
Let's start with pre-production,
where speed matters the most.
Directors can now move
from script into storyboarding instantly.
We capture tone, emotion,
framing, and visual continuity.
You can see here, we're exploring concepts
for a bird getting lost in the woods,
finally finding its parents.
And we can explore dozens and dozens
of different visual concepts for this
before we settle on what
direction we want to go.
And not only that,
but Ray3 also understands
cinematic language,
not just images.
Orbit right, dolly zoom, roll left.
It understands camera instructions
and other native filmmaking language.
So this scene demonstrates
lighting realism,
atmospheric physics,
performance consistency,
world coherence, all hallmarks
of cinematic quality.
Here you can see how the dust particles
filter through the flashlight.
That is typically a very
hard shot to achieve.
And now, we can get the shot
just by prompting for it.
This is a cute one we threw in.
Everybody loves the
hamster in the race car.
This one, with our animated pirates,
we were recently speaking
with a former Disney exec
who worked on "Pirates of the Caribbean,"
who told us that if they
had these kinds of AI tools
back then when they
were shooting the movie,
they would've saved over $20
million on production costs.
So animation is another area
where Ray3 reshapes workflows.
This 32-second animation
had a compute cost of just under $630.
It was made by a single
person in a single week.
Now for those of you that
don't know, get ready for this.
If you were using a
traditional animation workflow
with an animation studio, the
same 32 seconds of footage
would've cost between
$95,000 and $180,000.
It would require a crew of 14 to 20 people
and would take six to 12 weeks,
depending on iterations
and approval cycles.
Just think about that difference:
$90,000 to $180,000 versus
$630, one person, one week.
That is an enormous difference.
(lighter clicks)
(air whooshing)
(footsteps tapping)
(car door clicks)
(radio buzzes)
(dance music)
(person laughing)
(engines revving)
(singing in foreign language)
(crowd cheering)
(tires screeching)
(dance music continues)
(car screeching)
(helmet clicks)
- So Ray3 isn't just for
net new content either.
It's also a powerful VFX
and post-production tool.
Modify Video lets you relight, restage,
or retheme existing shots.
This is a great example where
we've taken a flat CG render
and we've produced a fully-lit, cinematic
final pixel version.
And we can make that scene
look any way we like.
It can be a snowy blizzard, an
apocalyptic fiery hellscape,
a city, you know, bustling at
night, whatever we ask for.
This is a great example of
relighting, mood shifts,
and fine-tune selective adjustments,
like inserting logos or brands.
This task normally requires multiple teams
across multiple departments.
Now, one person can do it in an afternoon.
So here, Ray3 can interpret
hand-drawn sketches
or blocking passes
and it can use that to
generate final shots.
It dramatically accelerates
the production phase.
They had a lot of fun making these.
You know, you can see we've got,
we just sketched the outline
of a car over our model
and now they're driving a car.
We can restyle the shot.
We can turn a toy into a
fully realized, finished shot.
So our video-to-video pipeline
preserves the structure and
motion of the base video
while transforming its
style, theme, or subject.
And you can change the level
of imagination on it as well.
You can adjust the strength
of how readily it changes things.
It's extremely useful for creators
that want to try multiple variations
of the same performance,
the same environment,
or different camera moves.
You can see we can pose
with a particular product,
we can turn John into a realtor there,
or we can completely change
the clothing on this model
as many times as we like.
- [Speaker 2] You have control.
- [Jason] So I'd like to draw attention
to how the depiction of
the sheep really snaps to
as soon as the actress goes
down onto hands and knees.
The model immediately recognizes
this person is dressed as a sheep,
we're gonna make them look as a sheep.
And with something as simple
as tying two shoes together
on an iPhone in your backyard,
you can turn that into a
high-octane police chase.
So speaking of high-octane,
let's talk about the gaming industry.
In gaming, Ray3 accelerates
the pre-production
and the ideation stages across genres.
Whether it's world exploration
or dungeon interiors
or high-intensity combat,
it handles spatial reasoning,
dynamics across very
different game aesthetics.
We can also reinterpret 2D sprite sheets.
It can expand on animations,
it can smooth motion cycles,
it can create new frames
that maintain the
original character design.
This is an example of
interpreting a text prompt
to display a targeted specific motion
with the sprite for 2D games.
We can make this orc
make any kind of movement
or action we ask it to.
This is huge for 2D game
production and mobile games.
So advertising is one of the verticals
where this technology is already
having an immediate impact.
What you're seeing here
are four completely different concepts,
different brands, different tones,
different visual languages,
all created in just a day.
Each of these could
easily pass as a TV spot
or a paid social hero asset.
But the key point here is this:
These aren't AI experiments.
These are production-grade ads
created without crews, without locations,
without sets, props, cameras,
or post-production teams.
So for agencies and brand studios,
Ray3 collapses the entire
traditional workflow pipeline.
There's no scouting,
there's no scheduling,
there's no retouching or compositing,
no expensive hero shoots.
It lets a single creative team
explore a dozen directions in parallel
and land on a polished, high-impact idea
in a fraction of the time
and a fraction of the budget
compared to a conventional
production pipeline.
So this sneaker commercial
is a great illustration
of what TV quality in 48 hours looks like.
Everything you see here,
the slow-motion kick,
the atmosphere, the dust
particles, the rim light,
it all normally requires
a full production team.
Here, a single creator produced
the entire spot end-to-end.
And for performance marketing teams,
this is a huge breakthrough.
You can launch dozens
of premium hero assets,
iterate on them instantly,
and then tailor every version
to a specific audience,
without ever shooting a second time.
- [Narrator 1] From the neighborhood
From the neighborhood
to the hardwood,
from potential
to superstardom.
They say you have to make waves
to be remembered.
I disagree.
When they told me
to make the ground tremble,
I stayed light on my feet
and walked on clouds
all the way to the top.
Step light.
- [Jason] Okay, this one is special,
because this one isn't just speculative.
This is a real commercial campaign.
This holiday spot was created
by Coca-Cola with Luma
in an incredibly tight turnaround window.
What made this possible wasn't just speed,
it was that Ray3
understands brand language.
So it understands the warmth, the glow,
the atmospheric winter feel,
and the emotional pacing
of a Coke holiday ad.
With traditional production,
this level of craft
takes large crews,
controlled environments,
specialized lighting, a long
post-production pipeline.
And with Ray3, a small team produced
a single, campaign-quality,
globally consistent holiday ad
at the speed that just
wasn't achievable before.
For global brands like Coke,
that time compression isn't
just operationally important,
it's strategically transformational.
- [Narrator 2] Hello, friends.
Today we are going to look
at something very special,
because, you know, they're
coming: the holidays.
- [Narrator 3] Welcome to the making
of the Coca-Cola 2025
"Holidays are Coming" ad.
- [Narrator 2] It really feels
like this work is, you know,
actively shaping how
storytelling is evolving.
It shows Coca-Cola
really re-imagining the creative workflow,
especially in this AI era.
Holidays are coming,
holidays are coming
Holidays are coming
(cap whooshes)
Holidays are coming,
holidays are coming
'Tis the season, watch out
- [Narrator 3] The look they settled on
is really interesting.
They tried a few things out.
Coming to your town
Something magic in the night
Can't you see it shining bright
- [Narrator 3] But they landed
on this super-expressive hyperrealism,
really cinematic scenes.
Holidays are coming,
holidays are coming
Holidays are coming
- [Narrator 3] The big
question is probably
how a tiny team, like five specialists,
how they managed to churn
out and carefully refine
over 70,000 video clips.
- [Narrator 2] 70,000.
- [Narrator 3] Mm-hm, in just 30 days.
That level of precision suggests
the team had to go way
beyond just simple prompting.
- Yeah.
- Shaping the animals,
getting the texture right,
those big sparkly eyes.
- [Narrator 2] Exactly.
Okay, so let's get into
this customized workflow they built.
- [Narrator 3] Right,
so it basically starts
with generative image models,
then it moves into these,
well, powerful video models
for the actual animation.
There's still a little post and
color tweaks, quick cleanup,
but the big shift is clear.
What we used to fix at the end,
we are now building right from the start.
- [Narrator 2] Post-production
is the new pre-production.
Advanced reasoning models
let artists plan and solve them early
and making scenes feel real
before production locks in.
- [Narrator 3] Last year was different.
Extensive post-production
fixes were required.
Wheels looked like they were
sliding instead of rolling.
Physics needed correction.
Logos had to be adjusted and repositioned.
Now, AI is enabling creators.
What used to be patching at the end
is now designing at the start.
- [Narrator 2] And they
needed a big toolbox
to handle 70,000 segments.
- [Narrator 3] A whole suite.
- [Narrator 2] Combining
human creativity with AI
to turbocharge expression and imagination,
giving creatives more
freedom, speed, and control
than ever before.
Holidays are coming,
holidays are coming
- [Narrator 2] And that's real magic.
- [Narrator 3] Exactly.
- [Jason] So to close,
I want to come back to a broader look
at where we're heading.
So this reel highlights the
mission behind the technology.
What we're seeing is the
beginning of a major shift
from video generation as a creative tool
to video generation as
a world modeling engine
that empowers anyone
to produce cinematic-quality stories
without legacy production barriers.
- [Narrator 4] When we started Luma,
(keypad clicking)
the founding vision of the company was
if we are able to capture
and then simulate the world,
that would have an
immense impact on humanity
and what we are able to achieve.
And what DALL-E proved
was that from nothing,
you can generate images.
But in order to generate
and understand the world,
we need to go way beyond.
- [Narrator 5] It's
called the Dream Machine,
created by tech company, Luma.
And it's available starting today.
- [Narrator 4] Ray3 was
a very small glimpse
what the pinnacle
of the previous generation
of models looks like.
That's not enough.
(intense music)
Our goal
is very simply, to solve
multimodal general intelligence.
(dramatic music ends)
- So this is what multimodal
AGI looks like in practice.
It's models that understand
the physical world
well enough to help us
create inside of it.
Thank you very much.
- When we started Luma,
the founding vision of the company was...
(audience applauds softly)